plusieurs confrères titre ce matin sur
la scandaleuse gestion de l'argent du
sida ce sont les titres
si l'on en croit le pré rapport de la
cour des comptes l' agence française de
lutte contre le sida qui est chargée de
la politique de prévention a été gérée
avec une incroyable légèreté la
multiplication des gaspillages est
d'autant plus choquant que les dépenses
ont été totalement inefficace marc
maisonneuve
le jeu des chaises musicales à la tête
de l' agence quatre directeurs en trois
ans pour un salaire de 560 mille francs
beaucoup plus que le montant prévu pour
la fonction 45% de rotation du personnel
le recours excessif à la télévision 950
mille francs dépensés pour l'intégration
d'un personnage séropositifs dans un
téléfilm d'une chaîne privée et les
préservatifs parlons-en
quatre cent mille francs dépensés pour
l'achat de préservatifs inutilisable
d'après la cour des comptes
le nouveau directeur lui tente de
minimiser sur quelque chose de minime
par rapport à la somme du fonctionnement
laisse plus grave pour la cour des
comptes
aucune action d'information d'envergure
n'a été destiné à la population immigrée
pourtant jugé très exposés les
toxicomanes n'ont pas eu droit à des
messages spécifiques hormis quatre
messages sur des radios délocaliser et
une toute petite brochure la sls est une
association à but non lucratif type loi
1901 et son budget est de 170 millions
de francs pour 93
afin sur une ville j'en ai plein les
poches
mais pas abattu ap